Es ist wieder soweit, wir blicken auf den europäischen Fußball bei den Männern. Heute sind mit dabei die Ligen Premier League, Eredivisie, Ligue 1 und La Liga mit Nils Kern, mit Nils Kern, Uli Hebel, Daniel Zander und Jakob Haffke. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ein fieser Bug hat uns die Hälfte dieses Intros vorenthalten. Euch nicht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn für euch hab ich's gefixt. Aber ich muss sagen, mir fehlt was. Aber was soll man tun? So ist die Technik manchmal. Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich freue mich sehr, hier wieder meine Runde begrüßen zu dürfen in einer Champions League Woche. Und Daniel Zander hat schon gesagt, als Fan des niederländischen Fußballs verfolgt man das gerade nicht so gern. Daniel, wo drückt der Schuh? Überall leider.
Moin erstmal in Runde. Ich sah es vor dem Fernseher und dachte, das kann nicht wahr sein. Ich komme auch noch später drauf zu sprechen. Also 4-0 hat Ajax verloren gegen Marseille und war wirklich chancenlos. Das war auch rein verkautscht. Und das war für mich auch der vollkommen falsche Ansatz, taktisch. Und es ist ja nicht nur Ajax. Also es hat immerhin Eindhoven den ersten Punkt geholt gegen Leverkusen, wo man aber auch relativieren muss und sagen muss, wenn das Leverkusen vielleicht mal ein paar Wochen eingespielt ist, sieht es vielleicht auch anders aus. Und der Punkt war auch dann total glücklich, wie er entstanden ist. Oder auch Feyernoord, die ja auch schon in den Playoffs gegen Navasche ein paar Wochen zuvor 5-2 verloren haben, obwohl sie in Führung lagen. Also das sieht man leider, dass viele der Top-Clubs in der Eredivisie aktuell noch diverse Probleme und Problemchen haben. Und dass sie noch nicht mithalten können mit Teams international, die schon weiter sind leider.
Ich habe versucht, während du gesprochen hast, ins Gesicht von Jakob zu blicken. Denn das muss ein bisschen gegenteilig sein, oder? PSG bei Barca gewonnen, Marseille haben wir ja gerade schon angesprochen. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht wenig, gerade noch vergesse, aber für die Ligue 1 läuft es besser.
Monaco. Ja, Monaco ja auch mit der 2-2 gegen City.
Eine völlig verdienten 2-2. Was haben die City an die Wand gespielt?
Ja, ja, nee, also klar, Monaco etwas glücklich gestern mit dem 2-2. Ansonsten aber gute Champions League-Woche bisher für Frankreich. Marseille sehr überzeugend, nachdem man ja auch am ersten Spieltag schon gegen Real zumindest phasenweise ganz gut aussah, meiner Meinung nach. Und PSG, Uli hat es ja gestern auch gesehen, war auch nicht so schlecht in Barcelona. Also die ersten 30 Minuten dachte man so, ja gut, aber dann war es dann doch wieder so ein bisschen mehr das PSG der letzten Saison.
Stimmt, Uli, du hast es ja kommentiert, Barse gegen PSG. Hat es das gehalten, was du dir versprochen hast?
Nicht ganz. Das klingt, das ist wirklich das berühmte Meckern auf allerhöchstem Niveau, aber es war Tatsache, weil jedes Team so seine Phase hatte und beide glaube ich keine so richtig zusammen. War jetzt nicht das versprochene und antizipierte Feuerwerk, so was man sich glaube ich auch vorstellt, wenn dann wirklich alle auch an Bord sind. Aber logischerweise hat es großen Spaß gemacht, ist ja klar.
Außer natürlich allen La-Liga-Clubs, Nils. Also da sehe ich eine sehr durchwachsene Bilanz. Ja, Real hat in Almaty 50.000 Kilometer von hier entfernt, 5 zu 0 gewonnen, genau, aber du winkst schon selber ab. Und ja, Atletico hat 5 zu 1 gewonnen, aber gegen irgendeinen unbekannten Club Eintracht Frankfurt. Weiß nicht, ob ihr davon schon mal gehört habt, aber eben Barca 1-2 verloren, Atletico Bilbao 1 zu 4 verloren gegen den BVB. Mixed Feelings in Spanien.
Ja, und dann gibt es noch das Viareal 2-2 gegen Juventus, also wenn man so auf die Tabelle schaut, Viareal 1 Punkt, Bilbao 0 Punkte, die haben auch verschiedene Probleme und Nicolio ist noch nicht fit und in der Innenverteidigung fehlen paar. Da merkt man, das geht noch besser, man merkt zumindest aber auch Atletico, wenn sie mal wollen, wenn sie mal gelassen werden, dann können sie diese ganze Qualität auch mal auf den Platz bringen. Das sieht dann phasenweise auch mal nach Fußball aus. Und ja, ich wollte eigentlich Uli nachträglich noch ein Zehner beweisen. Ich dachte, das ist schon Premium Content Fußball, aber dann war es vielleicht doch nicht ganz so gut, was ich phasenweise nur in den Highlights gesehen habe oder in der Zusammenfassung. Also teilweise kann sich schon sehen lassen, aber ja, ein paar Teams kommen noch nicht so richtig vom Fleck. Da fiel vielleicht noch die altbekannte, coole Champions League-Erfahrung abgezocktheit.
Du, ich hatte am Wochenende Hoffenheim in Freiburg. Da bin ich Besseres gewohnt.
Es ist so angenehm, wenn nicht ich die Bundesliga-Distracks hier verwendet. Ja, aber Uli, dann noch kürzer Blick auf die englischen Teams. Also die große Story ist natürlich Liverpool 0-1 bei Galah. Ansonsten, was würdest du sagen? Was ist so eine für eine Bilanz? Also wir haben ja auch das 2-2 von City angesprochen. Das war natürlich sehr ironisch gemeint, aber durch einen Strafstoß sehr spät mal Widerpunkte liegen lassen. Der Ausfallsflug von Pep, er funktioniert einfach, er liefert. Also was würdest du sagen, wie ist so die Bilanz aus englischer Sicht?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, weil ich ganz ehrlich bin, dass ich gestern gar nicht mehr in die anderen Ergebnisse reingeschaut habe, nachdem ich nach Hause bin.
Stimmt, ist eigentlich logisch.
Aber wer fehlt noch? Newcastle, glaube ich.
Newcastle hat bei Union Saint-Gélois sehr souverän, 4-0 gewonnen, sehr früh geführt. Dann haben wir Arsenal gegen Perreos, sehr lange 1-0. Das lief schon wieder so ein bisschen auf so eine klassische Arsenal-Pointe raus, das frühe Arsenal, aber dann haben sie es 2-0 irgendwie draufgesetzt. Und dann hatten wir ja noch die Spurs bei Brodö. Das war natürlich interessant, muss man sagen, gestern. Aber mit einem 2-2 sind sie da noch eigentlich gut rausgekommen, so wie das Spiel gelaufen ist.
Da werden sie noch andere schwer tun, weil die Reise macht niemand gerne mit Kunstraßen. Das ist, glaube ich, alles viel zu oft zitiert worden. Aber das Unentscheiden habe ich im Vorfeld einem Freund gegenüber gecallt, weil das war mir fast klar. Wahrscheinlich ist das dann okay für alle englischen Teams. Ungefähr so, was man sich vorstellt. Dort wird sich ein bisschen mühen. Newcastle, glaube ich, wird es wieder okay machen. Das ist quasi der erste Villaspot der Vor-Saison. Gut bei City ist, das weiß ich auch noch nicht ganz genau, wer die sind im Moment. Also das ist ganz seltsam, weil das ein Auf und Ab ist. Innerhalb von 90 Minuten die ganze Zeit. Da sind 10 Minuten dabei, sind richtig gut. Dann kommen wieder 15 Minuten, wo man merkt, wie fragil alles ist. Immer noch große Schwierigkeiten in der Spielkontrolle. Das hätte ich nie gedacht, dass ich das jemals über einen Pep Guardiola Manchester City sagen würde. Aber ja, deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich alles ungefähr so, wie man es hat erwarten können.
Und auch Chelsea gegen Benfica bei der Rückkehr von Jose Mourinho. Da gibt es Jose Mourinho 1-0 nur halt gegen sein Team. Aber das ist ja eh die beste Geschichte der Champions League bisher gewesen, dass Mourinho mit Fener die Playoffs gegen Benfica verliert, bei Fener entlassen wird und dann kurz danach bei Benfica einsteigt. Solche Geschichten, naja, ihr vervollständigt selber. Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, mit wem wir dann anfangen. Vielleicht mit einer positiven Geschichte. Nils, wenn du magst, dann lass doch mal in La Liga gehen. Da gibt es einen Elch, der rockt, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ja, ja, ein Elch, der rockt und ein Trainer, der aus einer ganz berühmten regionalen Fußballschule kommt, wo mittlerweile einige berühmte Trainer hergekommen sind. Und ja, wenn man so auf La Liga-Tabelle schaut, wir können über Real, über Athletico, über Barca reden, ja. Aber FC Elche fällt da bestimmt schon eher auf, denn die sind immerhin als Aufsteiger aktuell Tabellenführer und sind auch noch neben Barca das einzige ungeschlagene Team. Was waren es jetzt? 3 Siege, 4 Unentschieden. Also da schon mal eine stabile Bilanz. Auch schon Athletico, Unentschieden, abgerungen. Sie waren letztes Jahr schon in der 2. Division, lange in der Rückrunde Erster. Am Ende sind sie Zweiter geworden, auch als beste Defensive. Und das bestätigt mal wieder so diese alte Theorie. Wenn Aufsteiger mit einer sehr guten Defensive hochkommen, haben die eher Erfolg, als wenn ein Aufsteiger vielleicht mit einer guten Offensive hochkommt. Also das wirkt schon mal ziemlich stabil. Und ich habe den Trainer angesprochen, das ist Eder Sahrabiha. Der war früher mal unter Kike Setien bei Barca Co-Trainer. Dann zwei, drei Jahre beim Piquet-Club. Wie heißen die? Andorra-Trainer gewesen. Und jetzt hat er vor einem Jahr Elche übernommen, sie dann direkt zum Aufstieg geführt. Und der kommt eben aus so einer baskischen Trainerschule oder der ganzen Region, wo ja auch, ich meine, Miquelateta ist Baske, Lupitecchi hat der Erfolg, Immanuel Goazil von Real Sociedad, Una Emery, Xabi Alonso. Da kommen ein paar große Trainernamen her. Und jetzt muss man auch mal Edas Sarabia, da erwähnt der wie gesagt ein bisschen mit Elche, die Liga rockt.
Aber was würdest du denn sagen, spielt da alles zusammen? Also klar, gute Defensive, ungeschlagen. Wie viel Spielplan kommt da noch mit rein?
Ja, es ist nicht nur dieses, wenn ich jetzt gesagt habe, sie haben die beste Defensive schon gehabt. Und da ist es jetzt nicht nur der typische Mauerfußball. Sie haben nach Real Madrid und nach Barcelona jeweils die besten Ballbesitz und Passquoten der Liga. Also sie haben schon einen aktiven Spielplan. Das ist teilweise auch dann in einem System mit drei Innenverteidigern. Also es geht Richtung 3-5-2. Da versucht eben Sarabia mit seinen 44 Jahren, ist jetzt auch noch nicht alt, auch schon mal ein bisschen was Neues, was anderes, was man in der Liga noch nicht so sieht. Und deswegen ist es ein aktiv gestalteter Fußball. Ein paar Tiefenläufe, ein paar in der Offensive. Hast du ein paar Namen, wo Spieler vielleicht vermeintlich schon mal gescheitert sind? Rafa Mia hatte jetzt ein paar schlechte Jahre, Sevilla Valencia. André Silva, ehemals Leipzig und Frankfurt, war jetzt auch nicht immer gleich in La Liga eingeschlagen. Er hat jetzt auch schon seine drei Tore, wie Rafa Mia auch, von dem er da ist. Ein paar spannende Namen, die auf einmal funktionieren, mit Vertrauen des Trainers, mit auch ein paar jungen Jokern im Hintergrunden. Alvaro Rodriguez haben sie von Real aus geliehen. Hector Ford von Barca, Pedro Sá von Sevilla. Also da auch scheinbar ganz gute Scouting. Und dann gibt es sogar in der Innenverteidigung einen spannenden Österreicher. Vielleicht dieses Saison der spannendste österreichische David den Ligatour. Das ist David Affengruber, 24 Jahre Innenverteidiger. Der kam auch von Graz und der hielt auch eben dieses 352-System ganz gut zusammen und ist da aktuell voll gesetzt. Also wie gesagt, spannender Trainername, viele spannende Spielernahme, auch so ehemals gescheiterte vielleicht. Und das nicht nur mit Mauer und Konterfußball, sondern auch da viel Tiefe suchen, viele schnelle Bälle in die Spitze. Nicht ganz nur so auf bei Ramada, das ist manchmal ein bisschen statisch und wieder stoppen und nochmal gucken. Und bei Elche läuft das alles ein bisschen flüssiger, direkt da kann man sich aktuell ganz gut anschauen.
Uli hat sehr genickt bei David Affengruber, bei dessen Erwähnung. Also da haben wir auf jeden Fall Zustimmung in der Runde. Was würdest du denn sagen? Das eine sind ja quasi die Ergebnisse und da könnte man ins Detail reingehen, könnte auch sagen, naja, mit den beiden Clubs aus Sevilla und Atletico auch bessere Gegner gehabt, aber Seta Vigo, Ossasino, Oviedo und Levante, also es ist nicht zu erwarten, dass du da nicht verlierst und dass du da Punkte holst, aber es ist durchaus möglich. Aber jetzt mal abgesehen von den reinen Ergebnissen, glaubst du, das ist so die typische Geschichte, dass wir hier einen Trainer und vielleicht auch den ein oder anderen Spieler, du hast ja zum Beispiel Affengrubber genannt, sehen, die dann in zwei Jahren irgendwo groß auftrumpfen und wir sagen, wo kamen die denn her? Und dann erinnern sich nur alle Hörerinnen und Hörer an die Ligatour?
Ich horne, wird bestimmt der eine oder andere an die Ligatour hier sich erinnern, wenn Crystal Palace dann mal die 40 Millionen für den Affengrubber oder doch noch mal für Andries Hilver bietet, also wie gesagt spannende Namen, aber klar, es gab jetzt noch nicht die Duelle gegen Barcelona, gegen Remandre, da haben sich andere Teams, wie ich glaube auch schon Real Sociedad, die kommen später noch, die stehen weiter unten, weil die hatten schon diese Duelle und jeweils verloren, da fehlen dann halt schon mal ein paar Punkte, aber trotzdem für Elche geht es jetzt auch weiter dann gegen Alevis und so weiter. Deswegen, das kann erst mal so weitergehen, es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass der Athletic Club viele Probleme hat, Sevilla hat ein paar Probleme, also man sieht jetzt nicht automatisch, dass da mindestens fünf Teams, die noch überholen werden. Klar, wird am Ende noch um Real irgendwie davor stehen und vielleicht kann sich doch der Athletic Club ein bisschen sammeln, wenn Nico Williams zurück ist, aber doch, es sieht gut aus und wie gesagt, das einfach mit einem überraschend aktiven Fußballball. Weil in der Liga hast du viele Teams, die deutlich unter den 50 Prozent Ballbesitz haben, die es sehr destruktiv angehen, mehr Treter als Techniker vielleicht in den Teams haben. Das ist immer so ein bisschen mein Vorwurf an die Liga. Aber auch da generell, La Liga, es gab jetzt schon, ich glaube, es hat bis zum 61. Spiel der Saison gedauert, bis es das erste 0-0 gab. Das war sonst die letzten Jahre auch immer, gab es schon ein paar Null Nulls und auch früh, dass das Retafo und Cota auch nicht mehr angelegt haben. Von dem her vielleicht Elche ein bisschen sinnbildlich für die leicht positive Entwicklung in La Liga.
Also Eder Sarabia, den Namen merken wir uns. Wer weiß, wohin der noch kommt. Und vielleicht kann man den mal ja auch bei einer Bundesliga-Trenner-Diskussion einfach so reinwerfen. Und ansonsten möchte ich dir aber alle Sorgen nehmen. Nils, klar, vielleicht wird ein bisschen viel getreten in La Liga, aber man hat ja auch die besten Schiedsrichter Europas, wenn ich euch da richtig verstanden habe, in den letzten Jahren, die unabhängigsten und da gibt es nie Diskussionen. Und das beruhigt dann doch, tatsächlich, das ist doch gut. Also, Elche ist definitiv eine positive Geschichte dieser Saison. Und wenn wir in die Premier League schauen, Uli, da haben wir die nächste positive Geschichte, also eine von vielen natürlich. Aber jeder, der nur so ein bisschen mitverfolgt hat, was Crystal Palace unter Oliver Glasner so verfolgt hat, der hat mitbekommen, das ist ja sehr, sehr erfolgreich. Vor allem auch gegen Teams, gegen die sonst eigentlich niemand gewinnt. Liverpool zum Beispiel. Also was macht er denn so besonders?
Gute Frage, was er so besonders macht. Er ist offensichtlich ein hervorragender Fußballlehrer, weil das war jetzt nicht unbedingt drin gestanden in der Saison, dass die Widers so schwierig zu besiegen sein werden. Also das ist wahrscheinlich der Haupttrumpf von Crystal Palace. Ich schau gleich nochmal nach. Ich hab die Zahlen nicht mehr hundert Prozent in dem Kopf. Ich hab 18 Spiele wettbewerbsübergreifend in Folge, die sie jetzt nicht verloren haben. Das einzig unbesiegte Team in der Premier League, weil sie ja Liverpool inzwischen jetzt besiegt haben. Das heißt, sie sind da vorne weg im Moment. Und ansonsten hat er wieder ein Team geschaffen. Das war oder ist wahrscheinlich die absolute Errungenschaft. Er hat schon mal versucht in der vergangenen Saison, Glasner das Ganze weiterzuentwickeln, etwas spielerischer anzusetzen, mehr auf Umschaltmomente, etwas aggressiver im Pressing, also sie höher anlaufen zu lassen. Es hat nicht so gut funktioniert. Da hatten sie mal eine schwächere Phase drin. Sie waren nie abgehängt oder so. Sie waren niemals nur in der Nähe von Abgeschossen gewesen. Sie haben immer maximal mit einem Tor verloren, aber sie haben öfter verloren, vor allen Dingen für ihre Verhältnisse. Da gab es eine Phase Ende Februar, Anfang März. Da hat er wieder komplett umgestellt auf die absoluten Basics, die da heißen, wenn es geht, vorne hoch angreifen. In aller Regel haben sie aber schon die mit Abstand niedrigste Anzahl an hohen Balleroberungen im letzten Drittel, sozusagen, und sind das kompakteste Team. Das heißt, sie sinken so schnell, wie es irgend geht, ab in die absolute Kompaktheit und haben dann mit ihrer Fünferkette diese Prinzipien von sich gegenseitig, helfen in der Verteidigung absolut drin, wie wahrscheinlich kein Team. Also ist das wiedererkennbarste, bestgeschliffene Team im Moment in der Liga. Und das haben die Spieler gut verstanden. Plus, wenn du dich erinnerst, letzte Saison haben wir viel darüber gesprochen über Fitness. Das war auch Glasner als öffentliches Thema. Das hat er mir auch mal wirklich in Detail erklärt von Spieler zu Spieler, wo jeweils das Problem war. Ich habe ehrlicherweise gedacht, in diesem Sommer, das könnte wieder ein Thema werden. Da hat er sich aber diesmal gar nicht darauf eingelassen, sondern hat relativ gesagt, auch wenn wir dann noch Averagey Essay abgeben müssen. Das war sowieso von vornherein klar. Es war sogar verwunderlich, dass der so lange hat bleiben können. Aber das hat Glasner gar nicht gelten lassen und wähnte sich relativ früh in der Saison auf einen guten Weg. Ganz offensichtlich ist er da. Das ist ein sehr erstaunliches Team weiterhin, die großen Spaß machen und das, obwohl das ist ja öffentlich wahrscheinlich das einzige, was so in Deutschland so richtig angekommen ist. Und das, obwohl eigentlich auf dem Transfermarkt nichts passiert ist. Und das war komplett anders abgemacht. Es war ihm anders versprochen worden. Das kennen wir aus vor allen Dingen Wolfsburg. Das ist ungefähr die Wolfsburg-Situation, nämlich glaube ich, von damals, dass er da dann echt auch ungut werden kann. Und das ist er wohl intern auch geworden, auch wenn das öffentlich ein bisschen abstreitet. Aber der ist schon deutlich geworden. Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, dass der im Moment auf jedem Trainerstuhl in England, der halbwegs zur Verfügung steht, gehandelt wird. Die Engländer haben immer so ein ganz schwieriges Verhältnis zu den deutschen deutschsprachigen Trainern, vor allen Dingen denen, die jetzt nicht unbedingt glitzern nach außen. Aber das ist vorbei. Also Glasner ist final auch reputationstechnisch angekommen bei den absoluten Top-Trainer.
Und was glaubst du, wo der Weg von Crystal hinführen kann? Denn das eine ist natürlich positiv gelesen, erst diese drei Gegentore, das ungeschlagene. Also du hast ja gerade alles positiv gesagt. Negativ könnte man schon auch sagen, also hier durch die Conference League Qualifikation irgendwie mit einem 1-0 und einem 0-0 durchgekommen gegen Millwall, im Cup 5-3 nach Elfmeterschießen. Also hätten wir nicht dieses Last-Minute-Tor gegen Liverpool zum Beispiel gehabt, dann könnten wir ja auch über das relativ langweilige, graumäusige Crystal Palace sprechen.
Ja, also was mit der Conference League, Schreckstich Premier League passiert wird, das ist das Interessanteste wahrscheinlich am Ende, weil der Kader ist– das passt nicht, das ist zu wenig. Die erste Mannschaft ist okay, aber auch nicht mehr. Aber da haben sie komplett verpasst, was zu tun. Ich dachte, dass die am Deadline-Day wie so oft dann noch mal irgendwas machen, aber da haben sie auch sehr, sehr wenig reagiert, haben Pino geholt, das ist okay bislang, aber der trifft das Tor nicht. Das war es aber auch, ansonsten ist der Kader vergleichsweise dünn. Ich gehe ehrlicherweise davon aus, dass aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht müsste man Margae eigentlich noch verkaufen im Winter, auch wenn Glasner das gar nicht so unbedingt gerne hat, weil er natürlich inzwischen gebrannt mag und weiß nicht, ich hole mir eh nichts anderes, also will er ihn ungern abgeben. Das war auch das Thema, an dem es illustriert worden ist, dass er auch intern gesagt hat, okay, das könnt ihr schon machen, dass ihr den jetzt verkauft, aber wenn ihr dann keine Satz holt, bin ich weg. Und das wird sehr interessant zu sehen sein, wie sie dann in puncto fitness umgehen mit dieser dann wirklich sehr, sehr enormen Belastung. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite gibt es halt wenig Leute in dem Kader, die auch rausstechen auf dem allerhöchsten Niveau. Also da sind sie schon ein bisschen abhängig davon, dass zum Beispiel Ismail Asar, der kam jetzt am Wochenende wieder und hat gleich sofort relativ gut gespielt, hat man dann aber auch gemerkt, so ab der 70. das geht halt noch nicht wieder, der musste dann auch raus und wenn der nicht drauf ist, sind sie eine ganze Ecke schwächer. Matheta ist das Gleiche. Also man mag sich nicht vorstellen, was passiert, wenn der mal sich wirklich verletzen würde. Dann sind sie, weil in KT ja auch nicht so richtig, der hat jetzt am Wochenende zwar getroffen, aber der kann auch nicht so richtig gesund bleiben. Das ist ein Problem. Also da hat er nicht die Breite. Der zeigt es am besten auf. Letzte Saison hat er dann Justin Devaney hochgezogen, der aus der 2. Schottischen Liga gekommen ist. Der macht das okay, aber der dürfte niemals in der Nähe der ersten Mannschaft sein. Ich will ihm jetzt nicht zu nahe treten, aber das ist das Ligen-Bonnenniveau in etwa, was der hat. Der gibt Vollgas und den setzt Glasner so in Szene, dass es nicht großartig auffällt. Der musste letzte Saison dann plötzlich auf jeder Mittelfeldposition ran. Also von der 10 über die 6 über teilweise auch rechte Schiene oder so etwas, wenn Munoz nicht konnte. Also das ist alles eng. Das ist auf Krante genäht. Und das ist das, was Glasner auch von vornherein bemängelt hat, dass er da was bräuchte. Und das ist auch das, was ich bemängle im Übrigen. Die haben jetzt ein Fenster auf, haben zwei Titel geholt, wenn man Community-Shield mit dazuzählen möchte. Es wäre vielleicht sogar mal die natürliche Qualifikation für Europa möglich über die Liga. Das ist echt rarf, das zu schaffen. Aber es wäre nicht komplett unmöglich, so wie die unter Glasner gerade dastehen. Und der Verein macht, was auch immer er macht. Sie knausern, das muss man auch zur Ehrenrettung noch mal bitte zusagen. Ich habe mir aber von einem sehr, sehr guten Kollegen, und das hat mir ein anderer bestätigt, noch auch von vor Ort sagen lassen, das hat nichts damit zu tun. Die haben keinen Sportdirektor, immer noch nicht. Im März ist Dagi Friedman Richtung Saudi-Arabien gegangen. Das haben sie nicht ersetzt. Das ist das Vakuum.
Roland Wirkos ist frei. Ich sage es nur.
Nochmal bitte?
Roland Wirkos ist frei. Ich sage es nur. Ich muss aber zahlen. Der erst glatt, was er verkündet. Mach mal zu.
Dann ist alles klar. Da haben sie immer noch nicht ersetzt. Sie haben so eine interne technische Direktor-Halblösung gefunden. Aber alles, was ich höre, ist das nicht das Problem auf dem Transfermarkt. Sondern es ist keine administrative Sache. Sondern es ist eins, dass der Club einfach nicht... Sie machen irgendwie das Geld nicht locker. Sie sparen wohl immer noch Richtung Stand, der eröffnet worden ist, der wohl ein bisschen teurer geworden ist als geplant. Es ist kurzum aber nicht erklärbar, weil die haben jetzt so lange darauf gewartet, halbwegs kompetitiv zu sein und nicht immer nur Elfter zu werden oder Dreizehnter. Und jetzt sind sie in der Nähe, gewinnen den FA Cup, spielen Europa erstmals und machen weiterhin so wenig wie möglich und haben dann so einen Miniflicken-Teppich beieinander.
Ja, und gleichzeitig versuchst du, deinen Trainer zu schützen, in den du ihn 100 Millionen Euro Ablösesumme draufpackst, wenn er der Erste anfragt und vergraust ihn aber vielleicht dadurch, dass du dann doch zu wenig investierst. Ist aber auch eine schwierige Situation. Also ich verstehe es auch aus Sicht der Owner, weil so viele andere Vereine haben sich auch manchmal schon verhoben und wer weiß, wie viel davon von Uli Glasner tatsächlich abhängt. Also sollte er mal weg sein. Kann es auch sein, dass du auch mit einem besseren Kader da nicht so gut dastehst, weil, keine Ahnung, da Eji Kamada vielleicht seinen Uli Glasner braucht, um zu funktionieren. Wer weiß das schon.
Aber gut.
Wir beobachten es weit. Es ist auf jeden Fall eine absolut beeindruckende Bilanz und mindestens ein Pokal holt Uli Glasner. Ja, sowieso, das wissen wir ja. Das haben wir inzwischen aus der Vergangenheit gelernt. Die Frage ist, wenn wir nach Frankreich blicken, Jakob, wie viele Pokale wird PSG holen? Denn über die möchtest du jetzt mal sprechen. Da kommen wir ja auch tatsächlich mit der Steilvorlage von gestern Abend, wo es dieses 2 zu 1 gegen Barca gab, was wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben. Also bei wie viel Prozent des Vorjahres PSG, das ja, wir haben ja alle gesehen, wie gut das war, steht denn Paris deiner Meinung nach?
Tatsächlich bei noch nicht so viel. Da gibt es aber auch sehr gute Gründe für. Also es gibt zum einen natürlich die Club-WM, die Paris bis ins Finale bestritten hat. Dann hatten sie ein paar Wochen oder noch nicht mal ein paar Wochen, sondern ganz kurz Urlaub. Haben dann den Trainingsstart gehabt. Eine Woche später, nach dem Trainingsstart, Pflichtspielauftakt im UEFA Super Cup gegen Tottenham. Also wirklich gar keine Zeit, um die Grundlage für irgendwas zu schaffen. Und ja, das ist, glaube ich, das gab es wahrscheinlich noch nie wirklich. So eine inkomplette Vorbereitung für ein Team in Europa. Und es wird sehr spannend zu sehen, wie sich das auch über die Saison hin entwickelt. Also ob da die Grundlagenausdauer bei den Spielern komplett fehlt, ob man sich da irgendwie rüber retten kann. Also Luis Enrique hat es dann teilweise so genutzt, dass er in den ersten Pflichtspielen auch eher so Testspielaufstellungen in der Liga gebracht hat. Dementsprechend sind auch die Ergebnisse jetzt noch nicht zwangsläufig so, wie man es meistens erwartet von PSG, wo ja dann häufig mal ein 4-0, mal ein 5-0 oder so bei rumkommt. Das war jetzt alles eher knapp. Man hat auch schon das erste Mal verloren in der Liga gegen Marseille, wo man sehr zahnlos wirkte, nachdem man früh in Rückstand geraten war. Aber auch dafür gibt es gute Gründe, denn die Effekte der Club-WM zeigen sich auch schon in den Verletzten. Es ist natürlich nicht hundertprozentig sicher, dass es da herrührt, aber es ist schon sehr auffällig. Letztes Jahr hatte PSG fast gar keine Verletzten, wenn dann waren es immer nur ganz kleine Blessuren. Diese Saison ist fast jeder Spieler schon mal ausgefallen, denn Belé, Doué, zwei der entscheidenden Offensivspieler, fehlen jetzt schon seit Wochen, werden wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen fehlen. Da gab es auch Ärger mit der französischen Nationalmannschaft, weil aus PSG-Kreisen Didier Deschamps vorgeworfen wurde, dass er die Spieler nicht ordentlich gemanagt hat, obwohl sie vorher schon angeschlagen waren. Dementsprechend flogen da dann wieder ein bisschen die Giftpfeile hin und her. Es ist natürlich total bitter für Paris, dass jetzt beide lange ausfallen. Zumal auch Bradley Barcoulard schon fehlte, der war ja jetzt gegen Barca wieder dabei, hat am Wochenende in der Liga das erste Mal wieder richtig auf dem Platz gestanden. Hatte auch schon mit einer Muskelverletzung zu kämpfen. Quaratzkedia fehlt, hat sich im letzten Ligaspiel verletzt, musste da zur Pause raus. Ist wohl nicht so super schlimm, aber trotzdem passt es sehr gut ins Bild. Mit Marquinhos ist auch der Kapitän verletzt. Im zentralen Mittelfeld Joao Neves musste kurzfristig passen, nachdem erst gedacht wurde, dass er wieder spielfähig ist. Auch der fehlte schon. Fabian Ruiz war schon verletzt. Senyma Yulu, einer der Youngster, war verletzt. Vitinha war ein bisschen kurios. Am letzten Spiel gegen Auxerre wurde er nach 30 Minuten rund schon ausgewechselt, wirkte da nicht so richtig glücklich drüber, war wohl auch ganz leicht angeschlagen und Luis Enrique wollte dann wirklich gar kein Risiko eingehen, weil er halt sowieso schon komplett auf den Zahnfleisch geht mit dem Kader. Und man muss dann natürlich auch dazu sagen, der Kader ist auch sehr klein, das hatten sie in der letzten Saison auch schon, sie haben 19 wirklich etablierte Feldspieler eigentlich nur im Kader, was natürlich bei einer Dreifachbelastung nicht gerade viel ist, erinnert einen vielleicht so ein bisschen an die Bayern. Und man hätte vielleicht auch mehr machen können, wollte, konnte, ist so ein bisschen die Frage, konnte es bei PSG wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich die Option, dass man es nicht konnte. Aber es ist halt so, man wollte vielleicht nicht zu den Preisen, die es gab. Außerdem Marc-Louis Enrique eigentlich auch generell ganz gerne einen kleinen Kader, also kann man da durchaus auch mit Pep Guardiola vergleichen. Zumal es auch so ist, dass bei Paris halt im Kader sehr viele Spieler sehr flexibel sind, viele unterschiedliche Positionen spielen können. Und daraus resultiert dann auch, dass man halt so wie gestern gegen Barcelona dann auch die ganzen Ausfälle durchaus auffangen kann und sogar in der zweiten Halbzeit deutlich mehr zulegen kann, auch mit den Einwechselspielern, die dann von der Bank kommen. Also es ist dann bemerkenswert, man hat vorne mit Zenny Mayulu und Ibrahim Mbaye zwei Eigengewechsel in der Startelf gehabt. Mayulu auf der ungewohnten zentralen Stürmerposition, hat das auch eher so wie eine falsche Neun gespielt, hat das gut gemacht, hat ja auch den Ausgleich geschossen, war jetzt nicht so auffällig wie Dembélé, wenn er fit ist, aber ich glaube, das kann man auch nicht wirklich erwarten. Mbaye ist auch noch ganz jung, ein Flügelstürmer, der in der Liga teilweise auch ein bisschen blass geblieben ist, dann aber jetzt gegen Barca richtig gut reingefunden hat, auch ins Spiel, das war schon durchaus bemerkenswert. Gerade nachdem er dann mit Bacula auch die Seite getauscht hat, hat er da gegen Koundé einige ganz vielversprechende Aktionen auch drin gehabt und dann kommen halt von der Bank mit Gonzalo Ramos noch mal ein echter Neuner, der ja selten bei PSG auf dem Platz steht, der dann auch letztendlich das entscheidende Tor macht, halt genau das macht, was man will, wenn man denn mal einen Stürmer drin hat, also super starker Laufweg. Und dann schließt er ab, Kang-In Lee, glaube ich einer der unterschätzten Kaderspieler bei PSG, hat auch seine Füße maßgeblich im Spiel beim 2-1, also nimmt da unter Druck wahnsinnig stark den Ball an, löst dann das Pressing auf und leitet somit dann den Angriff eigentlich ein. Hat auch ansonsten in der Liga immer wieder richtig gute Spieler dabei. Man hat mit Sabani sich in der Innenverteidigung sehr gut verstärkt, hat da jetzt endlich ein gleichwertiges Backup für Marquinhos, was sich jetzt auch direkt auszahlt, wo er verletzt fehlt, hat auch sein erstes Tor gemacht in der Liga schon. Das war ja eigentlich klar, wer ein bisschen Bournemouth auch verfolgt hat in der letzten Saison, dass das gut funktionieren wird. Der passt da super gut rein, ist mit dem Ball richtig stark, kann den nach vorne passen, nach vorne dribbeln. Und dann vielleicht noch eine durchaus gravierende Veränderung auf der Torwartposition. Man hat das Gegenteil von dem gemacht, was City gemacht hat. Man hat also Donnarumma abgegeben und dafür einen Torhüter geholt, der deutlich fußballerisch besser ist mit Lucas Chebaye, der ja auch als zukünftige Nummer eins zumindest gilt in Frankreich, der jetzt teilweise auch schon seine Probleme hatte gegen Marseille, zum Beispiel auch das Gegentor verschuldet hat bei der Niederlage. Aber man merkt schon, dass PSG beim hinten Rausspielen deutlich mehr Sicherheit gibt, weil er einfach mit dem Ball am Fuß ein ganzes Stück souveräner ist. Und es ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen die Frage, wie sich das wirklich in den nächsten Wochen dann weiter verführen lässt. Kommen die Verletzten zurück? Gibt es noch mehr Verletzte? Weil jetzt einige wirklich fast jede Minute spielen müssen, weil halt die Optionen fehlen. In der Offensive müssen die Spieler eigentlich, wenn sie wieder da sind, direkt auch reingeschmissen werden, weil du halt nicht so viele Möglichkeiten hast. Aber grundsätzlich scheint das Ganze weiterhin ganz gut zu funktionieren. Das Mittelfeld ist stark. Die Außenverteidiger sind aus meiner Sicht die beiden besten Außenverteidiger, die es momentan gibt im Weltfußball mit Nuno Mendes und Ashraf Hakimi. Deshalb war jetzt auch gegen Barcelona die beiden die Tore vorbereitet. Es war schon sehr beeindruckend dann doch wieder die so nach einer halben Stunde, fand ich.
Und genau das ist ja, glaube ich, auch die Argumentation, die man fahren könnte. Also bei allen Problemen, die du ja genannt hast, Verletzte, Kadergröße, Club-WM, fehlende Vorbereitung und so weiter und so fort, muss man ja sagen, trotzdem in der Champions League einmal gegen Atalanta 4-0 gewonnen und jetzt 2-1 auswärts bei Barca in der Ligue 1, ja, okay, einmal gegen Marseille bei diesem verschobenen Spiel, also verschoben vom Datum her, verschoben verloren, keine Verschwörungstheorien aufmachen. Und ehrlicherweise, also ich will jetzt hier keinen allgemeinen Ligue 1-Disc loslassen, aber wir alle wissen ja über die Kräfteverteilung innerhalb dieser Liga. Das heißt, vielleicht schaffst du es da auch mit einem kleinen Kader und ohne eine richtige Vorbereitung bei Spielen. Also wie gesagt, es geht nicht gegen die Clubs generell, aber die nächsten Spiele in der Liga sind Lille und Straßburg, okay, das wird interessant, Brest, Lorient, Nizza. Wie gesagt, da kann man auch mal Punkte liegen lassen und das geht nicht gegen die einzelnen Teams, aber das kann auch reichen. Und in der Champions League bist du schon mal mit zwei Siegen gestartet. Also man könnte es doch auch genau andersrum formulieren, könnte sagen, ey, ist ja Wahnsinn, bei wieviel Prozent seiner alten Leistungsfähigkeit PSG schon wieder steht, trotz all dieser Probleme.
Ja, absolut. Also ich glaube auch, dass man da durchaus positiv darauf blicken wird. Und ich meine, Dembele-Douets kommen jetzt vielleicht auch nach der Länderspielpause schon zurück. Und wenn man das dann gemanagt kriegt, man kann halt in der Liga, wie du es gesagt hast, dann auch ganz oft nach 50, 60 Minuten die wichtigen Spieler mal rausnehmen. Das war ja auch einer der Gründe dafür, warum PSG in der letzten Saison kaum Verletzungen hatte. Und vielleicht kriegt man das dann tatsächlich ausgeglichen, auch die mangelnde Vorbereitung.
Also wir sind gespannt, wie es bei PSG weitergeht. Wer definitiv nicht in der 50-, 60. Minute schon die besten Spieler auswechseln kann, ist eigentlich jedes Team, das in der Eredivisie um den Meistertitel kämpft. Und das, obwohl uns Dani jetzt schon verraten wird, nach sieben Spieltagen, wer Meister wird. Daniel, ist es dann doch so eindeutig?
Ich lehne mich jetzt ein bisschen weit aus dem Fenster und solche Aussagen fallen einem ja dann doch gerne mal am Ende der Saison auf die Füße. Aber ich glaube, dass Feyenoord Rotterdam sehr gute Chancen haben wird, in der Eredivisie Meister zu werden, tatsächlich. Und das ist, das sage ich jetzt nicht zwingend, weil Feyenoord aktuell alle Gegner in gutem Boden spielt, sondern ich sehe den Grund eigentlich eher darin begründet, dass Ajax und Eindhoven mit sich selbst beschäftigt sind und sehr viele Problemherde haben, die sie löschen müssen. Und das nutzt Feyenoord oder wird Feyenoord, denke ich, mal ausnutzen. Die sind doch aktuell schon auf Tabellenplatz 1, haben bis 19 Punkte, Eindhoven auf 2.16, Ajax auf 3.15, sind also jetzt nicht wirklich weit weg. Aber gerade, um mal mit Ajax anzufangen, das Spiel vom Dienstag gegen Marseille hat eigentlich schon viel offenbart, warum ich denke, dass zum Beispiel so ein Ajax diese Saison in der Liga solide performen wird, aber jetzt nicht auf absehbare Zeit wirklich Chancen hat, Meister zu werden diese Saison. Jetzt sind vor allem zwei Sachen, die das Spiel gezeigt hat gegen Marseille. Das ist einmal, dass Trainer Dunheil Tinker durchaus in der Kritik steht. Bei diesem Spiel muss er sich die Vorwürfe gefallen lassen, durchaus vercoacht zu haben. Also er hat im Vorfeld der Partie auch schon angekündigt, sie wollen mutig sein, sie wollen pressen, sie wollen hochstehen. Das ist auch passiert. Und genau das war eigentlich auch das Problem. Also wenn man sich die Marseille-Spiele angesehen hat, die spielen ja durchaus sehr gerne schnell vertikal direkt. Und dieses 1 zu 0 ist eigentlich so symbolisch, wie Marseille die Tore erzielt. Ein langer Ball auf den Stürmer, der lag jetzt sofort weiter auf tief laufenden Spieler. Der ist frei vom Tor und war auch relativ, generell war Marseille sehr stark im Abfluss vom Tor. Und das wurde in der ersten Halbzeit eigentlich auch jetzt nicht von Heitinger irgendwie weggecoacht. Das wurde so laufen gelassen. Man ist so ein bisschen mit Ansage ins offene Messer gelaufen. Und das offenbart so ein bisschen die Probleme, die Heitinger bei Ajax aktuell hat. Dass er einfach das Ingame-Coaching und auch die Vorbereitung bei einigen Gegnern nicht ganz so optimal erwischt, sag ich mal. Und das war eigentlich jetzt der Gipfel von diesem Problem jetzt gegen Marseille. Und das andere Problem, was sich zeigt, ist generell ein bisschen die Abwehrarbeit von Ajax, die einfach so ein bisschen naiv ist. Das liegt natürlich auch darin, dass die Abwehrspieler sehr jung sind. Wir haben einen Juri Baas mit 22, wir haben Anton Gai mit 22, wir haben einen Alters mit 20, sehr viele Jugendspieler. Jetzt haben sie natürlich Ida Kura geholt aus Klappbach mit 28, sehr erfahren, solide. Das war auch wichtig. Und der hilft auch der Ajax-Defensive. Aber er alleine kann es ja auch nicht stemmen. Und man hat auch in der Liga schon gesehen, dass sie hier und da mal sich ein Gegentor fangen wegen Abstimmungsproblemen, wegen Naivität. Und das in der Gemengelage zeigt, dass Ajax letztendlich da immer mal ein bisschen anfällig ist. Und ein generelles Problem von Ajax ist auch, dass sie das der Anspruch und die Wirklichkeit aktuell auch ein bisschen auseinanderklaffen. Man hat jetzt Hato verkauft zu Chelsea für 40 Millionen. Man hat Broadway verkauft nach England für 20 Millionen. Und man ist gerade auf einem guten Weg dabei, so ein bisschen in diese Hublade des Ausbildungsclubs zu rutschen, was ja per se nicht schlecht ist. Nur zeitgleich hat man den Anspruch selber, dass man trotzdem Meister wird oder zumindest mitspielt, dass man trotzdem gut abschneidet in der Champions League. Und das sind zwei Ziele, die sich eigentlich so ein bisschen, die nicht zwingend kurzfristig Erfolg verschaffen. Du kannst nicht deine guten Leute alle verkaufen und dann von den Jugendspielern erwarten, dass sie sofort funktionieren. Und das ist aber gerade so ein bisschen die Richtung, in die es bei Ajax läuft. Ich glaube, dass die Spieler, die sie haben, echt Potenzial haben, auch in den kommenden Jahren, ebenfalls nur gute Rollen zu spielen. Aber es ist eben mittelfristiges Ziel und nicht kursfristig.
War das früher nicht die Philosophie von Ajax? Sorry, wenn ich da so reingrätsche. Also genau das, was du beschrieben hast. Spieler verkaufen, Jugendspieler hochziehen und Europa trotzdem irgendwie gut mitspielen. Haben wir ja wieder und wieder gesehen, auch wenn es natürlich schwieriger geworden ist. Das ist klar.
Sie haben damals natürlich immer auch, wenn sie dann für sehr viel Geld einen Delicht oder einen D-Jongen oder wen auch immer verkauft haben, dann aber nicht ausschließlich Jugendspieler dafür benutzt, um diese Lücke zu füllen, sondern haben dann auch mal ein bisschen mehr Geld in die Hand genommen, damit sie eben auch Erfolg haben, kurzfristig. Und jetzt fehlt so ein bisschen der, sag mal, Boom-Effekt oder der einschlagene Transfer. So Mitakura bringt Solidität. Klar, es ist solide. Aber es ist jetzt keiner, der vielleicht die Abwehr auf ein neues Level hebt. Und sie haben diesen zweigleisigen Weg ein bisschen verlassen, auch einfach aus finanziellen Gründen, damit sie sich ein bisschen konsolidieren können, damit sie ein bisschen Einnahmen vorweisen können und verpassen es dann doch auch mal um diese Jugendspiele herum noch ein zwei weitere größere Namen zu holen, die es zumindest dann braucht, wenn die Marschroute ist, wir wollen jetzt auch mithalten können in der Champions League. Und das ist so ein bisschen einfacher. Ich habe ja überhaupt nichts gegen diesen Weg. Aber das Problem ist, dass dann zeitgleich der Anspruch gestellt wird an diese vielen Jugendspieler, dann auch jetzt erfolgreich zu sein sofort. Und das ist natürlich dann auch einfach ein nicht dingender Ermöglichkeit, aber zumindest sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig. Und sollte eigentlich dann auch nicht so den großen Druck ausüben. Und das Ganze auf Brücken von Donald Tinger, der es jetzt ausbaden muss, der auch selbst Fehler macht, wie jetzt gegen Marseille, der aber es endlich natürlich auch dann zusehen muss, dass er mit sehr, sehr vielen Talenten schnell Erfolg hat. Und da sind sie in der Liga eigentlich auf dem okayen Weg. Sie sind noch ungeschlagen nach sie im Spielen, was okay ist. Aber du hast dann immer vor allem gegen kompakt stehende Teams Probleme, da noch mal kreativ durchzukommen. Und da fallen ihm auch nicht so die Lösungen ein. Also deswegen denke ich, dass Ajax in dieser Saison in der Liga solide performen wird. Aber die Lücke zu Feyenoord ist schon da. Und die wird, glaube ich, auch nicht kleiner im Verlauf der Saison.
Und wie ist das bei PSV? Also bei PSV sind ja die Gründe für auch externe leichter zu finden, weil wir haben viele der Abgänge mitbekommen. Malik Tilmann zu Leverkusen, Johann Bakayoko zu Leipzig, dann noch Noah Lang zu Napoli. Und nichtsdestotrotz hängt der PSV. Also sie fangen gut Gegentore, aber sie schießen auch viele. Also 21 zu 11 nur zum Vergleich. Feyenoord hat 15 geschossene Tore und nur 4 kassierte Tore. Das ist ein deutlicher Unterschied. Drei Punkte Rückstand kann man ja im direkten Duell noch regeln. Also warum bist du dann auch bei PSG, PSV skeptisch?
Ja, das ist der Faktor Zeit, den ich da einfach sehe. Du hast ja nicht nur diese offensiven Abgänge. Und das typische, das Klischee PSV Eindhoven ist sowieso genauso, wie es aktuell performt. Wir schießen unfassbar viele Tore und haben unfassbar viele tolle Spieler im Offensivbereich. Aber immer geht es zu Kosten auf Abstimmung und immer fangen wir uns auch Tore. Und deswegen, diese Offensivabgänge, sehe ich gar nicht mal so als Problem an. Also man hat jetzt auch mit Player zum Beispiel oder mit Rüben von Bommel, dem Sohn von Marc von Bommel, auch gute Offensivkräfte geholt. Die sind jetzt verletzt, das ist auch ein Teil des Problems. Aber man hat trotzdem noch so viel Qualität im Angriff. Ein Saibari, ein Mann, ein Till, das sind ja alles sehr gute Offensivkräfte, die ja einspringen können und das auch tun. Als Probleme sehe ich in den Verkäufen im defensiven Bereich. Da hat man zum Beispiel Boska Liefa verloren zu breiten. Und da muss jetzt Flamengo eigentlich mehr in diese Rolle des Abwehrchefs rein. Der ist selbst noch sehr jung. Und man muss jetzt die große Bürde, dann kommt jetzt die große Aufgabe und würde da mehr Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Und auch Malek Tilmen, der kann man auch offensiv zählen, aber der eigentlich so das Bindetlied war, dieser Mittelfeldmotor war. Und da sieht man eigentlich auch in den Spielen schon, dass der Mittelfeld so ein bisschen Struktur verloren geht. Und da ist die Abstimmung, die im Mittelfeld sowieso ohnehin bei PSV immer ein Thema ist, noch schwieriger geworden. Und da ist das defensive Umschaltspiel mindestens ausbaufähig. Und deswegen haben sie eben auch schon diese Elfgegentore in der Liga gefangen. Unser Vergleich, PSG Zwolle auf 14 hat auch Elfgegentore. Und das ist dann auf Dauer ist dann– oder auch hier so ein Breda auf 5 hat nur eins mehr Herren, auf 16 hat auch nur eins mehr. Also da sind sie schon in dem unteren Bereich der Liga. Und ich glaube, dass es einfach Zeit braucht, bis das wieder sich die Waage gibt. Plus eben auch die Verletzungen, die sie ja auch haben. Gerade ist es unglaublich bitter. Du verkaufst De Jong, der auch in der Kabine sicherlich wichtig war, als in der Team-Hierarchie nach Porto. Und verkaufst Vakai Joko, was du zu Altflung gesagt hast. Und dann kommen Claire und Van Bombel. Und die sind beide mit schweren Verletzungen raus. Die werden dieses Jahr nicht mehr spielen für PSV. Und da haben sie ein bisschen viel Pech. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass das einfach der Fakt, was bei Feyenoord ist. Denn Feyenoord an sich ist auch gut eingespielt. Ist sehr solide. Die haben von diesen vier Gegentoren, du sagst es, die haben davon auch nur in einem Spiel drei bekommen. Also die haben fünf Spiele zu Null gespielt von diesen sieben. Auch noch ungeschlagen. Eindhoven hat auch schon gegen Telstar Aufschlagertzwelle verloren. Das ist diese Inkonstanz. Eindhoven gewinnt auch mal 6-2-1 gegen Sparta zu Beginn der Saison. Und im guten Tag und am Flächen verlieren sie eben zwölf Euro in den Aufsteiger. Und das hat Feyernoord eben nicht. Die haben so dieses 4-2-3-1, die spielen relativ defensiv, trotz der 15 Tore, aber haben halt dadurch eine Sicherheit und haben es dann vorne diese individuelle Qualität, das sie endlich haben. Und die haben auch mit Sam Stein, die hatte ich hier auch schon mal vergangen, ist ja, glaube ich, als Winner of the Match, MVP, so rum, der ist neu zugangen bei Feyernoord, der ist auf Andi Kapitän geworden, was auch schon glaube ich viel aussagt, und hebt das Mittelfeld von Feyernoord auf ein neues Level. Und das merkt man schon. Das heißt, diese Abgänge auch von Peijau, der im SA jetzt auch gegen Ajax getroffen hat, zweimal gegen ihre alten Rivalen, haben sie Gutfallkraft für Dueda im Sturm bei Feyernoord, ist sehr dynamisch, sehr agil, macht das gut. Und mit Sam Steyn haben sie auch einen Garanten, auch einen Torchubsenkönig der letzte Saison, der ihnen noch viel Freude bereiten würde. Und deswegen lehne ich mich aus dem Fenster und sage, wie machen wir das schon? Mal gucken, ob es stimmt. Vielleicht bin ich in einem Viertel-Spiehtag und muss den Gaggener Klosser antreten, man weiß es nicht.
Ja, aber es ist ja schön, mal so früh schon so eine Einschätzung zu bekommen. Und mit Robin van Persie hat man ja auch keinen so ganz unbekannten Trainer. Das soll noch kurz erwähnt sein für alle diejenigen, die es nicht mehr auf dem Schirm haben. Also, werden wir den Blick behalten und jetzt machen wir nochmal eine schnellere Runde durch die Ligen. Nils, wenn du denn technisch verfügbar bist, wir hatten ja ein paar Abstürze. Schön, dass du wieder da bist zum zweiten Mal. Worüber sprechen wir denn noch in La Liga? Schnell, bevor es zum nächsten Absturz kommt.
Ja, jetzt auf dem zweiten Laptop müsste es klappen, auch wenn ich jetzt zwei hier negative Themen habe. Die kann man beide vergleichen, weil beide hatten letztens Champions League und sind jetzt nach Abstürzen, nach Leistungsträger abgebend. Sind sie im Tabellenkeller. Da fange ich mal an mit dem FC Girona. Der fällt vielleicht am meisten auf, wenn man Tabelle anschaut, weil noch ohne Sieg und die waren letztes Jahr eben in der Königsklasse. Und da gab es sie schon nach ihrem starken Run in der Liga. Es sind ja schon viele Leistungsträger, Dolfik und so weiter, weggegangen. Auch in diesem Sommer irgendwie hat sich die City Group gedacht, ach komm, so ein Miguel Gutiérrez, Janko Herrera, Langhiere Leistungsträger braucht man doch nicht mehr.
Das wurde dann aufgefüllt.
Girona ist so ein bisschen ein Flickenteppich. Es gab nie die gleiche 11. Keiner hat irgendwie alle sieben Spieltage gespielt. Wurden mal so, wo wäre es gerade frei auf dem Transfermarkt? Ach, Axel Witsel, der ist bestimmt noch schnell. Nein, ist er nicht mehr. Thomas Lemar auch von Atleti, der hat doch gut funktioniert. Nee, hat er nicht, den holt man sich an so ein paar. Merkt man so ein bisschen, das ist ein bisschen random zusammengewürfelt, der Kader. Und ich bin gespannt, wie es da weitergeht, denn sie haben sie ja noch so ein Notnagel von City geholt mit, wie heißt es, Vitor Hayes. Vielleicht kann ja im Winter auch noch in die Pep Guardiola kommen, um irgendwie da was zu retten. Aber die war letztes Jahr schon, ich glaube, die zweitschwächste Defensive der Liga. Auch jetzt irgendwie lassen die drittmeisten Abschlüsse zu. Sie sind hinten ein ziemlicher Höhner auf dem Machen, viele Fehler. Und konnten eben diesen Adalast der letzten ein, zwei Transferperioden noch lange nicht auffallen. Noch hat Trainer Mitchell da das Vertrauen. Aber sie stehen nicht ganz unverdient unten auf dem letzten Tabellenplatz. Sie sind noch nicht mal auf Riamatri oder Barcelona getroffen, wo man sagen kann, okay, da wird es wahrscheinlich eher 6 Punkte, kannst du dir abziehen. Haben wir auch bei Elche schon gesagt. Und trotzdem hat Girona irgendwie erst drei Unentschieden geholt aus diesen sieben Spieltagen. Also das sieht nicht gut aus. Aber sie sind vielleicht auch verschmerzbar in der Liga. Sie haben das kleinste Stadion, sind der Club mit den wenigsten Mitgliedern. Von dem her haben sie erst ihre sechste Saison in der ersten Liga. Von dem her gäbe es vielleicht größere Verluste in der Liga.
Aber hat sich denn was im Verhältnis zu City, also Girona gehört ja zur City-Group, hat sich da was verändert? Denn City wiederum und die ganze Group, die haben ja ein Interesse an den spanischen Erstligisten.
Ja, was heißt, die haben natürlich ein Interesse, dass dort Spiele geparkt werden, um dann groß aufzuspielen, wie es ja mit Savio oder Savinho war in dieser einen überragenden La-Liga-Saison, wo sie am Ende 4. oder 3. geworden sind. Der ist ja dann direkt zu City gegangen. Es gab auch ein paar andere Spieler schon mit City vergangen, halt Janko Herrera und noch ein, zwei andere. Aber jetzt ist eben nur dieser Vitor Reis, glaube ich, da, weil man sich vielleicht auch denkt, wenn man Spieler verleihen, dann vielleicht eher wohin, wo vielleicht noch Europapokal Hoffnung besteht. Also ist da Girona noch lange nicht fallen gelassen, sonst wäre ein Reis, wie gesagt, da nicht hin. Aber sie hatten schon mal mehr Verstärkung, glaube ich, von ihrem Mutterclub oder wie man das sagen kann.
Du willst im Multi-Club-Ownership nicht der Feeder-Club sein, sondern derjenige, der die Ernte einfährt. Und das ist Girona definitiv nicht. Wir schauen es uns weiter an. Was wir nicht mehr sehen, ist dein Video. Dadurch, dass du jetzt den Laptop gewechselt hast, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, euch ist es egal. Und liebe Zusehenden bei YouTube, wir können es leider nicht ändern. Immerhin ist Nils da. Deswegen wirst du hier nämlich die ganze Zeit als offline angezeigt. Jetzt ist es mir gerade aufgefallen. Nee, das kriegen wir jetzt leider so schnell nicht mehr gefixt, ohne die Aufnahme komplett neu zu starten. Stattdessen schauen wir lieber noch mal nach England in die Premier League. Auch da, Uli, in guter alter Tradition hast du uns ein Positivthema, nämlich Palace, mitgebracht. Und jetzt kommt ein Negativthema. Bei West Ham sieht es nicht ganz so schlimm aus wie bei Girona, denn immerhin einmal konnte man schon gewinnen, aber mit dem vorletzten Tabellenplatz ist es auch nicht so wahnsinnig gut. Was ist da los?
Ganz viel. Also viel ist auch von dem, was schon letzte Saison war, was auch mit transportiert worden ist und schon die erste Trainerentlassung. Und das ist dann was, was mich sehr überrascht hat. Graham Potter hat eigentlich den Auftrag gehabt und ist damit angetreten, dass er die Defensive ganz gerne stabilisiert hätte. Mit hinzu vor allen Dingen war immer die Devise. Das hat eigentlich auch okay geklappt, ganz zunächst, also die ersten zwei, drei Monate. Komischerweise war davon nichts mehr zu sehen. Also es war ganz, ganz seltsam defensiv anfällig vor allen Dingen und dazu ist aber auch ansonsten nichts gekommen, was richtig funktioniert hat. Und was jetzt so langsam, aber sicher rauskommt, ist, dass er sich ganz seltsam verhalten haben soll, Graham Potter intern, also sich mit einigen Spielern, zum Beispiel Jared Bohn, der einzige, den man nennen kann, aus den letzten beiden Jahren, der so was wie positive Schlagzeilen geschrieben hat. Ich muss mir schon überlegen, ob ich da jetzt irgendjemand zu nahe trete. Nee, ich glaube aber nicht. Also, wahrscheinlich so der ultimativ einzige, über den man nichts, sagen wir mal so, nie irgendwas Negatives hat sagen können in Spielen. Oder andersrum, wo wären die ohne den? Und dem hat er öffentlich, als Kapitän geworden, hat er öffentlich so ein Kapitänsthema angehängt, was total seltsam war, weil er hinterfragt hat, ob das der Richtige ist, was grundsätzlich nachvollziehbar ist, aber in der Phase irgendwie ein bisschen abstrus, wenn es der Einzige ist, der wirklich performt. Dann hat er sich mit einzelnen Spielern so leicht zerkriegt, soll eine ganz seltsame Ansprache hier und da gewählt haben, was noch komischer ist, weil das einer galt, der überdurchschnittlich emotional intelligent ist, hat er ja auch einen Abschluss gemacht. Und das war eigentlich immer so seine Superkraft, dass er mit Menschen gut kann, aber das soll bei West Ham jetzt überhaupt gar nicht gewirkt haben. Und das haben wir letztes Jahr auch schon mal besprochen, weil es ist im Grunde das gleiche Thema. Sie haben an jemanden festgehalten, von dem sie auch im Sommer schon wussten, das funktioniert nicht. Der Besitzer wusste, hat von Anfang an nicht mit Graham Potter zusammenarbeiten wollen. Der hat immer noch viel, viel zu viel Einfluss. Hat aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen weiterhin durchgewinkt, mit ihm in die Saison zu gehen, hat dann lange an ihm festgehalten. Und das war genau die gleiche Situation wie bei Lopetegi. Der wusste auch alle Beteiligten schon nach zwei Spielen, okay, sorry, das wird nichts. Und sie haben es bis Weihnachten durchgezogen. Jetzt haben sie es mit Potter immerhin nur bis Oktober durchgezogen. Sicherlich auch, weil die Opportunität passiert ist, dass Nuno Espíritu Santo auf einmal auf dem Markt ist, bei dem niemand gerechnet hat, dass er da auftauchen würde. Jetzt haben sie den genommen. Und es ist so ein Merkmal des Kaders, dass viele sehr sensible Spieler da drin sind. Also Spieler, die sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit one on one brauchen von Managern. Und die dann am besten sind, wenn rundherum möglichst wenig Probleme da sind. Das haben viele Fußballer, aber im Besonderen sind da ein paar drin. Paquetá zum Beispiel, der auch andere Probleme hat mit drohender Strafe und so, die das ganz gut vertragen können. Völkruck übrigens, habe ich auch noch vergessen, hat auch ein Riesenthema gehabt mit Graeme Potter. Das ist kein großes Geheimnis, dass der gar keinen Bock auf Völkruck hatte. Und das ist dann auch keine Überraschung, dass der sofort wieder im Kader steht, in dem Moment, als Nuno Espíritu Santo übernimmt. Das würde auch voll funktionieren. Der würde ihn zu seiner Chris Wood Projektreihe hinzufügen. Und vielleicht ist das das Beste, was Völkruck je passiert ist. Also kurzum, die haben, die haben so sehr mit sich zu kämpfen. Bei West Ham, mit Kader, mit dann auch Dingen. Also Graeme Potter ist irgendwie auch jetzt durch, wahrscheinlich in der Premier League. Und dieser Stint hat jetzt nichts Positives hinterlassen. Also ich muss mich auch offensichtlich sehr stark von ihm getäuscht haben, weil ich immer dachte, dass das ein richtig guter Fußballer ist. Der wird irgendwo in Skandinavien wahrscheinlich wieder oder keine Ahnung, geht er nach in die Niederlande. Deutschland gab es ja auch immer mal Interesse. Der wird sicherlich irgendwo nochmal zeigen, dass er ein guter ist, glaube ich, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das so mies war. Der wirkte auch so, das war das Schlimmste, so teilnahmslos war offensichtlich wurscht am Ende. Und das ist das Schlimmste, was man in einem Arbeiterviertel we-western machen kann, dass man sich nicht mehr wehrt. Und das haben sie ihm sehr übel genommen. Und jetzt schauen wir mal, was mit Nuno passiert. Das Gute ist, es gibt mindestens 3 schwächere Teams in der Premier League. Sie haben viel zu viel individuelle Qualität, das das Ganze nach unten krachen könnte. Aber ich würde mich nicht mehr zu viel spielen, aus ihrer Sicht.
Also dann sind wir mal gespannt. Und dann sind wir mal wirklich gespannt, ob es den Santos-Effekt bei Fülkrug gibt. Das wird man ja dann auch hier in Deutschland wahrscheinlich wieder mitbekommen. Jakob, wir blicken nochmal nach Frankreich. Wir haben vorhin schon mal indirekt über Straßburg gesprochen. Es wird jetzt die große Herausforderung, dass wir nicht zu lange werden, denn bei Straßburg gibt es ja eine ganze Reihe von unterschiedlichen Themen. Auch Multi-Club-Ownership spielt da eine Rolle. Aber vielleicht beginnen wir mal kurz mit dem Sportlichen.
Ja, es sorgt auch so ein bisschen dafür, dass man jetzt bei Straßburg gar nicht so richtig sagen kann, ob es positiv oder negativ ist. Weil du hast gerade erstmal nach dem Sportlichen gefragt und da sieht eigentlich alles ganz gut aus. Man ist nach sechs Spielen auf Platz 5, hat viermal gewonnen schon. Also steht total im Soll, steht eigentlich genau da, wo man ja auch letzte Saison die meiste Zeit stand, was ja damals noch eine recht große Überraschung war.
Genau.
Weil es ist auch diese Saison wieder so. Man hat einen unfassbar jungen Kader. Ich habe eine Studie gefunden, da werden 69 Ligen der Welt in dieser Saison betrachtet. Da ist Straßburg das zweitjüngste Team mit 21,45 im Durchschnitt in der Startelf. Da ist nur ein Team aus Lettland noch jünger. Und wenn man das auf die europäischen Top 5 Ligen bezieht, das zweitjüngste Team hat Paris Saint-Germain, die dann mit 24, also fast zwei Jahre älter sind. Ne, drei Jahre sind es ja sogar fast. Also es ist wirklich extrem, wie das da durchgezogen wird.
Wie viele Chase die Liga haben, sind dabei?
Man darf hier nur drei Spieler vom gleichen Verein leihen, deswegen sind es nur drei. Aber auch das ist natürlich ein bisschen fraglich. Da komme ich auch gleich noch mal zu.
Yes.
Es ist nämlich, was ich erst noch sagen wollte, dass man halt total den Eindruck hat, dass es eine sehr luxuriös geführte zweite Mannschaft ist. Man hat zwei Feldspieler im Kader, die über 23 sind. Das sind zwei Linksverteidiger, Eduard Zobol, ein Ukrainer und Ben Shilwell. Der ist nicht ausgeliehen von Chelsea, sondern ablösefrei gekommen von Chelsea. Man könnte auch sagen, der wurde da abgeladen. Der war ja bei Chelsea auch nicht mehr so gern gesehen. Er hat jetzt auch ein bisschen gespielt, aber noch nicht so sonderlich viel. Mal gucken, wie groß seine Rolle sein wird. Er kann natürlich allein aufgrund seiner Erfahrungen, die ansonsten kaum vorhanden ist im Kader, denke ich mal schon eine durchaus wichtige Rolle spielen. Andererseits hat Straßburg auch im Sommer wahnsinnig viel Geld bewegt. Also haben fast 200 Millionen an Transferumsatz gemacht und haben da einige Spieler auch verkauft, mit Dylan Buckbar zu Forrest nach England. Auch Javi Diarra ist nach England gewechselt zu Sunderland. Man hat zwei der wichtigsten Spieler, die von Chelsea ausgeliehen waren, abgegeben, mit Giorgio Petrovic, dem Keeper, der letzte Saison einer der besten Torhüter in der Ligue 1 war. Und auch Andrés Santos, der eine sehr positive Überraschung war. Und im zentralen Mittelfeld hat er jetzt bei Chelsea auch schon ein bisschen gespielt zumindest. Er kommt da nicht wirklich in die Stammelf, was jetzt auch nicht verwundert, wenn man sich das Mittelfeld bei Chelsea anguckt. Aber bei Straßburg fehlt er auf jeden Fall sehr. Und dafür geholt hat man vor allem wieder ganz viele junge Spieler, keiner ist älter als 23, außer Ben Chilwell. Und da hat man auch ein paar wirklich interessante Spieler geholt, mit Lukas Heusberg aus Dänemark, ein ganz junger 19-jähriger Innenverteidiger von Nordseeland, der ein wahnsinnig komplettes Paket ist, auf den ich sehr gespannt bin, wie der sich jetzt noch entwickelt hat. Auch schon einmal gelb-rot gesehen für eine ziemlich dumme Aktion, wo er den Ball aufgenommen hat, obwohl er schon im Spiel war, mit der Hand. Aber ansonsten macht das schon einen ganz guten Eindruck. Man hat mit Joaquin Panicelli einen neuen Stürmer noch geholt, der auch schon drei Tore gemacht hat jetzt in dieser Saison. Also auch schon ganz okay funktioniert. Man hat von Chelsea drei junge Spieler ausgeliehen. Mamadou Sarr, dann mit Mats Pendas noch einen Keeper, der auch mit 20 jetzt schon Stammtorwart ist. Und Kendry Paez, der auch mit vielen Vorschusslorbeeren zu Chelsea schon gekommen war, jetzt auch schon ein Tor gemacht hat für Straßburg. Die anderen Neuzugänge spielen jetzt nicht unbedingt alle die größte Rolle bisher. Aber es läuft halt sportlich trotzdem ganz gut. Und man muss da sagen, dass der Trainer Lea Morisinho auch weiterhin wirklich gute Arbeit macht, auch diesen Umbruch jetzt bisher zumindest gut schafft zu managen. Man muss jetzt natürlich ein bisschen schauen, wie es läuft, wenn auch die Conference League so richtig losgeht. Da hat man sich auch in der Quali eher so durchgewirkt. Und da geht es ja dann jetzt heute Abend auch los, ob dann vielleicht diese Mehrfachbelastung zum Problem wird. Aber ansonsten, sportlich ist alles durchaus positiv.
Okay, und dann kommen wir zu dem Nichtsportlichen. Also man muss dazu sagen, damit alle auf demselben Stand sind. Straßburg gehört seit 2023 zur Blue-Co. Und das ist quasi die Eigentümer- schaft, zu der auch Chelsea gehört. Und wir haben da ganz viele Spielertransfers schon gesehen. Wir haben auch so nette Konstrukte gesehen, wie da eine Spieler, den wir verkaufen und direkt wieder zurückleihen. Der kostet komischerweise genauso viel wie denjenigen, den wir gekauft haben. Und irgendwie kommen wir da auf Null raus. Also allein das könnte man alles schon hinterfragen. Und dann haben wir aber vor allem ja noch einen aktuellen Anlass, über dieses Konstrukt zu sprechen. Weil mit Emega ein Spieler, nachdem ich glaube dritten Spieltag, inklusive Geschäftsstellen-Foto verkündet hat, nächste Saison, also es waren wirklich drei wunderschöne Spieltage hier. Leute, ich werde sie nie vergessen. Aber nächste Saison spiele ich übrigens für Chelsea. Und das hat für ein bisschen Aufruhr gesorgt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, definitiv. Und man muss dazu noch sagen, dass Emega auch im Sommer erst zum Kapitän gemacht wurde, der Mannschaft. Also auch da dann noch mal eine andere Rolle spielt. Er war letztes Jahr auch einer der entscheidenden Spieler, ist ein wirklich super interessanter Stürmer. Der bringt alles mit. Und man kann schon verstehen, dass Chelsea den auch haben will. Aber ich glaube, das hätten alle Seiten ein bisschen besser lösen können, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, er posiert da im Chelsea-Trikot. Das hat natürlich bei den Fans für sehr viel Ärger gesorgt. Es gab gegen Le Havre im Ligaspiel große Proteste gegen ihn. Die Fan-Organisationen haben ihn dazu aufgefordert, auch die Kapitänsbinder abzugeben. Bisher ist da nichts passiert. Emega war jetzt auch ein bisschen verletzt. Dann war zweimal Joker, hat jetzt gegen Marseille, aber auch wieder in der Startelf gestanden. Und auf dem Platz liefert er auch weiterhin. Also hat auch schon vier Scorer-Punkte gesammelt jetzt in dieser Saison. In den vier Einsätzen, die er hatte, ist eigentlich halt unverzichtbar. Auch wenn jetzt Panicelli als neuer Stürmer ganz gut eingeschlagen hat. Es gab im Zuge dieses Emega-Transfers dann auch nochmal vermehrte Proteste von den Fans gegen die Gluko Group, die ja die Eigentümer sind und auch der Präsident Mark Keller wurde zum Rücktritt aufgefordert. Also der Präsident von Straßburg wurde zum Rücktritt aufgefordert. Ihm wird vorgeworfen aus den Fan-Kreisen, dass er halt nur das Sprachrohr von Gluko sei und sich nicht für den Verein Straßburg einsetzen würde. Das zeigt natürlich einfach, wie glücklich sich jeder Fan, glaube ich, schätzen kann. Der Fan eines Vereins ist, der nicht die 2., 3., Geige in einem Multi-Club-Ownership spielt. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir den Ausblick nach Deutschland brauchen, aber es könnte jedem Verein in Deutschland blühen, wenn man sich Investoren öffnen würde. Natürlich. Dass man nur noch Zulieferer-Club für irgendwen anders sein könnte. Ich glaube, so richtig will das keiner. Was auch noch super absurd war in diesem Transfer-Sommer, der Transfer von Julio Enciso, auch der hinkt zusammen mit dem Multi-Club-Ownership. Da gab es nämlich die Meldung, der wird wechseln von Brighton, aber wohin geht er denn jetzt eigentlich? Dann hieß es erst nur, er wechselt zur Pluco Group, weil man noch nicht genau wusste, wo er denn jetzt landen kann. Chelsea war sich nicht ganz sicher, ob sie ihn im Kader haben wollen. Dann war aber klar, wir können ihn nicht verleihen nach Straßburg, wenn wir ihn bei uns im Kader haben, weil wir schon mit Saar, Penders und Paez, diese drei Ligen, die zwischen Clubs möglich sind, ausgereizt haben. Und dann, nach ein paar Tagen, wurde dann klar, er geht tatsächlich zu Straßburg, die ihn dann gekauft haben. Er hat jetzt auch bisher noch nicht gespielt. Mal schauen, wo er letztendlich landet, ob er bei Straßburg spielen wird, ob er im Winter oder nächsten Sommer vielleicht bei Chelsea auftaucht. Wer weiß das schon.
Da wird es harte Verhandlungen gegeben haben, weil Chelsea ja schon wusste, Straßburg muss kaufen, weil sie haben ja schon drei von uns geliehen. Da haben die den Preis aber richtig nach oben getrieben. Also es ist einfach nur zu hassen. Ich sage es, wie es ist und ich möchte einmal diesen Punkt hier gemacht haben, weil der in der Debatte eine viel zu geringe Rolle spielt. Es laufen jetzt gerade wieder Leute rum aus aktuellem Anlass und erzählen, sobald die Bundesliga sich für Investoren öffne, dann könne man endlich mit Premier League auf Augenhöhe und man könnte dann wie Manchester United und der HSV, Riesenverein und Schalke usw. usf. Überlegt mal ganz kurz, was ist denn das wahrscheinlichere Szenario? Ist das wahrscheinlichere Szenario, dass jemand kommt und sagt, das hier ist der eine Verein, in den ich investiere, weil ich die Bundesliga so geil finde und hier stecke ich jetzt richtig, richtig viel Geld rein oder ist nicht das viel wahrscheinlichere Szenario, dass jemand sagt, ich habe schon fünf Vereine, geil, jetzt kann ich noch eine Bundesliga einhaben. Nachwuchs ist ja bei denen eh gar nicht so schlecht, aber weiter ist mein Premier League Verein die absolute Nummer eins und dann bist du nämlich dann bist du der HSV nur im Gewandetes von Racing Straßburg oder eben ein…
Titelvorschlag für die Folge, ey mega dieses Multi-Club-Ownership, weil ich hatte eben das Gegenbeispiel Girona, wie schnell man dann vermeintlich fallen gelassen wird vor zwei, drei Jahren, alles super, auch Top-Fußball gespielt und jetzt unser aktuell tabellenletzter mit wenig Hoffnung, dass das besser wird, aber ja also Racing Straßburg, nächstes Jahr Champions League und dann in drei Jahren auch irgendwie Abstiegskampf. Mal gucken.
Ja und das ist ja sowieso schon ein Problem, dass du das Gefühl hast, dass als Fan bist du der Einzige, der bleibt beim Verein. Alles andere wechselt durch. Spieler, Manager, Trainer und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist sowieso schon schwierig manchmal mit anzusehen, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit dadurch gewechselt wird und weil auch oft gar nicht mal so getan wird, als ob es jetzt wirklich um den Verein geht, sondern es geht halt um die Möglichkeit, dort Fußball zu spielen, was ein Stück weit legitim ist, aber als Fan kann dir das weh tun. Und das wird einfach so pervertiert durch Multi-Club-Ownership. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Und das kommt nach Deutschland. Wenn 50 plus 1 fällt, dann muss man sich gar keine Illusionen machen. Warum sollte es anders sein? Es gibt kein einziges logisches Argument. Deswegen wollte ich den Punkt hier nochmal machen. Ich beruhige mich jetzt und wir blicken nochmal auf die Ehre Divisi. Das macht vielleicht mehr Spaß, wobei ich gerade gar nicht genau weiß, ob dieses Segway funktioniert. Was macht denn Luis Holtby bei Breda? Macht er denn Spaß?
Er macht Spaß, aber ich will einmal, was die Bilder mal aufgreifen, weil ich weiß, wir haben leider ein Negativbeispiel, wenn man nach Bethesda Arnheim schaut.
Das stimmt.
Die ist, glaube ich, ein Multi-Club-Ownership, aber die haben auch verschiedene Investorengruppen gehabt und konstrukte. Und aktuell sind sie in der zweiten Liga mit minus fünf Punkten tabellenletzter. Das sagt auch schon viel über Punktabzug und alles. Sie waren auch sehr, sehr kurz davor, überhaupt die Profil-Gizenz entzogen zu bekommen. Und erst bei einer Berufung, die wurde jetzt erstmal Schachtel geben, dürfen sie jetzt auch erstmal spielen. Also das auch da ist ein weiteres Negativbeispiel für Investoren, die auch schnell keine Lust mehr auf ihr Spielzeug haben. Und dann hast du einen Club mit einer sehr reichheitlichen Geschichte, auch mit vielen Lines und Chelsea. Ich weiß, der Anderen war da auch immer sehr eifrig dran. Und die sind jetzt in der zweiten Liga mit minus fünf Punkten. Und wie es da jetzt wirklich bei dir geht, ist da auch noch offen. Aber wenn wir jetzt zum spaßigen Teil kommen, dann kommen wir zu der Lügis Holpik-Nachtphase. Ich glaube, ich habe in einem Interview gelesen, der war so ein bisschen auf das Geld in Saudi-Arabien aus, im Nahen Osten. Und dann kam wohl der Anruf von Breda, und der hat dann sofort zugesagt. Und ist da jetzt auch relativ schnell zum Fan-Liebling aufgestiegen. Was auch damit zu tun hat, dass er am zweiten Spieltag gebetiert hat und gleich das 1-0 dann gegen Sittard geschossen hat. Das Spiel haben sie am 2. gewonnen. Also das war ein perfekter Einstieg. Und er passt so ein bisschen zu dieser neuen Philosophie, die Breda jetzt sich angeeignet hat. Vergangene Saison hatten sie einen sehr mutigen, sehr offensiven Ansatz gewählt und versucht auch mit schnellem Kurzpass-Spiel da voranzukommen, was auch eigentlich gut funktioniert hat. Und jetzt versuchen sie so ein bisschen einen rustikaleren Ansatz, also mehr über Zweikämpfe zu kommen, mehr über Körperbetonteil. Und die Rolle füllt Holt B auf die Doppel-Sechs halt auch einfach hervorragend aus. Und das passt sehr gut. Breda ist jetzt noch mal nicht so erfolgreich, sie ist auf 15, haben aber auch schon zweimal gewonnen und haben jetzt auch gegen Ajax nur 2 zu 1 verloren zuletzt, was auch respektabel ist, weil sie sich ein bisschen so auf diese Kompaktheit konzentrieren und das eigentlich auch gut machen. Und Holt B hat auch schon gleich eine eigene Fan-Nummer bekommen. Also auf diese Melodie von Mackerkontakt haben sie da auch irgendwas gleich wieder gesungen. Und was auch immer interessant ist, sind ja die Ätymologie der Namen, die Herkunft der Namen, der Vereinsnamen. Und NAC Breda heißt, das N steht für Neut-Op-Reven-Allt-Teil-Dorsetten, also niemals aufgeben und immer weitermachen. Und das passt ja eigentlich gut zu Holt B, ist mir so aufgefallen, so ein bisschen sinnbildlich. Unser Vorständigkeit halber, das A steht für andere Namen der Vermarkt, der Nütter, der Ruhr und Spanning. Also angenehm durch Unterhaltung und Mehr davon bitte. witzig für Entspannung. Und das ist eine Fusion aus diesen zwei Vereinen. Das waren die Leiter dieser beiden Vereine. Und das C ist Kombinazi, also Kombination. Das heißt, der vollständige Name von NAC Breda wäre dann nicht obrevent, allzeit dorsetten. Andere Namen der Vermarkt, der Nütter, der Ruhr und Spanning. Kombinazi Breda. Und das nur als Randnotiz. Und ja, Nils Hortby fast zum ersten Teil zu Niemals aufgeben. Eigentlich doch ziemlich gut. Und ist sofort angekommen, ist auch, was man so hört, bei der Mannschaft sehr beliebt und kann relativ, ist ein gutes Beispiel, wie man relativ schnell zu einer ganzen Identifikationsfigur werden kann. Ist nach sieben Spieltagen und davon nur sechs gespielt, ein Spiel relativ schnell, ist aber eigentlich schon so Faktor um Bord. Ich habe, ich kriege eine gute Chancen aus, dass sie dann auch mal dieser Mentalität dann auch drin bleiben in der Liga.
Ich habe nur noch eine Frage. In der Vereinshymne von NAC Breda wird da der Name komplett ausgesprochen und ist die Hymne direkt danach dann vorbei? Ist das der komplette Refrain?
Nein, es wäre möglich. Es wäre lauig möglich, aber das haben sie sicher doch nicht getraut. Aber es gibt, das könnte man auch mal irgendwie mehr beleuchten, es gibt da wirklich tolle Siebblüten von Vereinsnamen in den Niederlanden.
Ja, wir haben ja schon die Go Ahead Eagles hier rechtzeitig abgefeiert, bevor sie dann auch auf die nationalen Medien hier aufgesprungen sind. Okay, wir blicken noch einmal kurz nach Spanien. Auch hier geht es eher um einen Verein, der Probleme hat, Nils.
Ja, das sind jetzt nicht ganz so gravierende Probleme wie vielleicht beim FC Girona, auch wenn die Parallelen da sind. Real Sociedad hatte vor zwei Jahren Wahnsinn in der Champions League, damals noch mit Miquel Merino, Robbele Normand, da gab es dann auch eben zwei Leistungsträger, die sind weg, hatten dann letzte Saison schon Probleme in La Liga. Jetzt in diesem Sommer ist dann auch noch Soubih Mendy auch zu Arsene, top Transfer, kann man nur gratulieren. Nur merkt man das auch bei LAR Ealteste da aktuell, sogar drittletzter sind fünf Punkte aus sieben Spieltagen. Ich würde aber da sagen, da ist die Lage nicht ganz so prekär wie zum Beispiel Girona. Real Sociedad hatte zum Beispiel schon die beiden Duelle mit Basel, mit Real Madrid da null Punkte rausgeholt. Bei ihnen, bei den Basten ist so ein bisschen eher das Problem. Erst mal gab es jetzt auch den großen Wechsel im Sommer. Immanuel Alguacil nach sieben Jahren hat ja unter anderem die Copa gewonnen, hat selbst erkannt, dass der Zyklus ein bisschen vorbei ist, dass es was Neues braucht. Er kam damals aus der zweiten Mannschaft. Jetzt ist auch Sergio Francisco aus der zweiten Mannschaft hochgezogen worden. Er war damals sogar der Nachfolger von Xabi Alonso in der zweiten Mannschaft. Also die setzen viel auf Nachwuchs. Sie haben eine große Jugendakademie, holen viele Spiele raus. Da steckt schon viel Nachhaltigkeit und Zukunft auch drin. Nur ihr großes Problem ist so ein bisschen eher die Effektivität. Sie hatten ja jahrelang, waren auch gut verwöhnt. Da waren mal ein Alexander Isak da, ein Alexander Sirloot. Silver zum Beispiel hat nicht geklappt und auch andere Spieler. Und so haben sie jetzt aktuell mal XG-Werte zu nennen. Haben sie nur 7 Tore erzielt, aber laut XG in der Liga hätten sie eigentlich 11 Tore haben müssen. Nur Raio hat einen noch schlechteren Effektivitätsschnitt. Also, sie spielen sich schon ein paar Chancen aus. Da sind immer noch ein paar gute Kicker wie ein Oya Zabal, wie natürlich auch Take Kubo. Der hat da auch mal ein bisschen kritisiert, dass der Kader noch nicht so richtig wettbewerbsfähig ist. Dann kam am Deadline-Day, glaube ich, noch ein Carlos Soler und eben Jan-Kyl Herrera aus Girona. Also, das wird schon, glaube ich, noch. Aber wer auf die Tabelle schaut, wird sich wundern, was ist da passiert. Vieles passiert, wie gesagt, es ist Ubi Mendyweg, der Trainer, weg jahrelang. Von dem her, da spürt man noch so ein bisschen diese Folgen dadurch.
Dann sind wir mal gespannt, ob sich Lareal noch fängt. Uli, wenn wir auf die Premier League noch ein letztes Mal blicken, ich weiß nicht, ob du ein drittes Thema noch mit dabei hast. Ansonsten habe ich auch einen Vorschlag.
Ja, schlag was vor. Mir fällt schon noch was ein, aber schlag gern was vor. Chelsea wäre lustig, oder?
Hau ab, ey. Wenn man auf die Tabelle blickt, dann fällt einem in den Top 6 vor allem ein Team auf. Also über Bournemouth haben wir schon oft genug gesprochen und das angedeutet. Aber Sunderland auf 5. Ich will mehr wissen.
Oh ja, da willst du sehr gerne zu Recht Dinge wissen. Das ist das für mich interessanteste Team im Moment, weil ich überhaupt nicht wusste, was ich aus denen machen würde in der Saison. Es gibt ja immer einen Aufsteiger, der einfach wahllos ein Kader zusammenstellt. Sunderland schien auch so ein Team zu sein, wo ich gedacht habe, entweder das wird voll funktionieren oder es geht halt komplett in die Hose, weil du deinen Aufsteigspirit sozusagen komplett weg gibst. Aber die haben, also Abib Deraa ist schon mal ganz kurz gefallen. Das ist einer von 2, die es mir totaler angetan haben. Noah Sardikis ist der andere. Die haben so 6er, 8er Hybridin. Das ist Wahnsinn. Das macht einfach nur großen, großen Spaß. Und auch ansonsten sind die einfach sehr, sehr gut gecoacht. Haben von Regis Le Bris eine ziemlich direkte Art und Weise an die Hand gekommen, das gefällt mir gut. Mit Xhaka, wie so in der Basis der Triangeln 433. Und dann haben sie jeweils so 2 ganz breite Dreiecke. Und dann gibt es noch jemanden dazu, wie zum Beispiel Chris Rigg ist hochinteressant. Und Talbi, der dann auch neu gekommen ist, der dann auf dem Außen steht, auch so einer. Und so kommen die relativ gut. Defensive spielen sie übrigens Mann gegen Mann, was auch Harakiri auf der einen Seite sein kann. Aber sie lösen es sehr, sehr gut. Und haben einfach die Nutzen, ihre Körperlichkeit. Und das ist was, was mir bei Thunderland bis dato sehr gut gefällt. Also scheint für mich fast der Aufsteiger zu sein, der die höchsten Chancen hat, drin zu bleiben. So ganz hundertprozentig bin ich mir bei den anderen noch nicht sicher. Burnley ist mal so, mal so. Aber die sind wahrscheinlich weg, würde ich sagen. Die sind einfach zu schwach individuell. Da fokussiert sich vieles auf Jaden Anthony. Und bei Thunderland sind es gleich vier, fünf Leute, die mir echt gut gefallen. Enzo Lefe, wenn er spielt, ist wie so ein kleiner Magier fast. Und auch ansonsten haben sie mit Anildo zum Beispiel einen Außenverteidiger noch geholt, der es schon sehr gut macht. Der Torhüter, den wird Daniel noch ganz gut kennen, den Ruf, den sie verpflichtet haben. Also keine Ahnung, warum da sonst niemand draufgesprungen ist. Der sieht sehr gut aus, muss ich echt sagen. Von daher, Sunderland, die geben so ein bisschen den Looten-Ipswitch-Spot der letzten Jahre ab von einem Aufsteiger, von dem man denkt, ja, das sieht gut aus. Jetzt hoffe ich, dass sie es beibehalten und nicht einknicken und nur noch kompakt spielen irgendwann. Weil sonst, glaube ich, geht es so wieder flöten. Sondern das muss weiterhin so sein, das ist ja aggressiv. Das ist eine Pressing-Liga und wenn du nicht presst, wirst du bestraft in England. Das ist einfach so. Und wenn sie das aber beibehalten, dann– also ich habe das in unserem Podcast auch schon so gesagt– ich rang 17, 16, traue ich ihnen echt zu.
Vielleicht noch irgendwann Tore schießen. Sieben Tore nach sechs Spielen, das sind ein paar mehr, wenn es schön ist.
Ja, das stimmt, zumal die auch zumeist in den einzelnen Spielen gefallen sind. Das war auch schon letztes Jahr aber so ein leichtes Thema, dass sie da nicht in der Champions League so hundertprozentig zu den Dingen gekommen sind. Die haben keinen so hundertprozentigen Goalscorer drin. Das stimmt. Aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, die machen auch noch mal was im Winter. Die haben da großen Spaß dran gefunden.
Ey, und mit Granit Xhaka an der Triangel, was soll schiefgehen? Was für ein wunderschönes Bild.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine der most random Transfers, die es gibt. Hängt auch wohl ein bisschen mit Eric den Haag zusammen. Der könnte dann bald wieder über Ajax übernehmen vielleicht. Also, das habe ich irgendwie nicht ganz verstanden, nachdem er ja ins Rheinland eigentlich zurück wollte, aus persönlichen Gründen, wie man das damals verstanden hat, glaube ich, Richtung Leverkusen. Er hätte auch Glattbacher nochmal gemacht oder irgendwas anderes. Und dann, also, ja gut, von dort aus in den Nordosten Englands. Ja, okay, warum nicht?
Vielleicht hat er die Doku gesehen. Kann ja sein. Also, Sunderland haben wir damit auch noch abgehandelt. Jakob, wir schauen nochmal kurz auf die Ligue 1 und auf ein allgemeines Thema. Die Karten, sie sprudeln nur so in der Ligue 1. Was ist da los?
Ja, es gibt sehr viele Platzverweise und vor allem ständig glatt rot. Also es gab jetzt nach sechs Spieltagen schon 18 Platzverweise in der Ligue 1. 15 Mal glatt rot, dreimal gelb rot. Das macht 0,33 Platzverweise pro Spiel. Also es ist wirklich beeindruckend. Man liegt damit europaweit, also unter den Top 5 liegen weit vorne. Man muss dazu sagen, die Ligue 1 ist da traditionell recht weit vorne auch immer. Aber in dieser Saison wird das wirklich so ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben. Es haben nur fünf Teams noch gar keinen Platzverweis kassiert, einige auch schon mehrere. Und es gab auch so ein paar besonders bemerkenswerte Platzverweise. Es gab zum einen jetzt am letzten Wochenende bei Startrennen gegen RC. Lons, gab es direkt nach 54 Sekunden, müsste es gewesen sein, eine glattrote Karte für Lons Jonathan Grandy, der da auch für eine Notbremse vom Platz gestellt wurde. Lons hat es tatsächlich geschafft, das Spiel noch 0 zu 0 dann auch über die 90 Minuten zu bringen, also hat sich da wacker geschlagen in Unterzahl. Und Startrennen hat irgendwie bei den spektakulären Spielen immer so ein bisschen die Finger im Spiel. Da gab es nämlich auch schon am zweiten Spieltag ein Spiel, wo Startrennen nach 11 Minuten schon zu neun nur noch war, weil sie zweimal glattrot gesehen haben. Da ist erst mir die Kamera für ein hohes Bein im Mittelfeld bei seinem Debüt für Startrennen, nach fünf Minuten schon vom Platz geflogen. Und dann gab es nach zehn Minuten und vier Sekunden noch mal glattrot für Christopher Wu, der da auch eine Notbremse noch gezogen hat. Und Startrennen hatte auch am ersten Spieltag schon eine glattrote Karte gesehen, für auch ein recht hartes VL-Spiel. Also da hatten sie dann drei rote Karten in den ersten beiden Spielen. Das Spiel haben sie dann auch verloren, 4 zu 0 gegen Lorient. Und dass es tatsächlich auch war, dass der schnellste Doppelplatz verweist, den es in der Liga, zumindest seit Obta aus der Saison 92, 93, die Daten erfasst gab. Davor war der Rekord von Bastia auch gegen Startrennen, allerdings damals für Bastia. Und es waren noch zwei gelb-rote Karten innerhalb von 16 Minuten. Tatsächlich war auch die rote Karte nach 54 Sekunden nicht die schnellste. Es gab vor ein paar Jahren mal eine rote Karte für Jean-Claire Tudibau, als er noch bei Lidzawa war. Das dürften nur so 12 oder 13 Sekunden gewesen sein, also eigentlich direkt vom Anpfiff weg. Und ja, auch europaweit sucht das so ein bisschen seinesgleichen, diese schnelle Doppelrote Karte. Ich habe mal geguckt, es gab das in der Serie A 2005, mal im Februar, auch nach elf Minuten zwei rote Karten für die Fiorentina bei Sampdoria. Wir haben ja jetzt keinen aus der Serie A dabei, aber sicherlich auch bemerkenswert. Und ja, es ist echt krass, wie viele Spieler in der Liga jetzt vor immer vorzeitig den Platz verlassen mussten in dieser Saison.
Also da können wir sehr gespannt sein, ob das so weitergeht oder ob sich das irgendwann noch einpendelt auf dem für die Liga normalen Niveau. Aber auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert und haben ja vielleicht auch manche Hörerinnen und Hörer schon mal so am Rande mitbekommen. Also gerade dieser Platzverweis nach 54 Sekunden. Das war ja durchaus auch Thema. Daniel, wir blicken noch ein letztes Mal.
Ich habe noch kurz was dazu zu sagen. Es gibt natürlich auch wieder aus der Liga Kritik an den Schiedsrichtern.
Ja, die Jury sind schon, sehe ich auch so. Klar.
Viele Trainer beklagen sich, dass die roten Karten zu hart sind. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, bei einigen Notbremsen ist auch so ein bisschen die Frage, ob das wirklich eine Notbremse ist, weil da dann oft noch Spieler so nebenbei auch waren, wo man sich fragt, hätten die nicht noch eingreifen können. Und ansonsten sind aber auch viele rote Karten wirklich vermeidbar, würde ich mal behaupten.
Ja, ansonsten einfach Schiedsrichtertausch mit La Liga und dann wird das mit dem Niveau alles passen.
Ich bin ja auch aller Ligen immer sehr zufrieden mit den Schiedsrichter.
Genau, also generell. In der Bundesliga habe ich jetzt keine Diskussion mitbekommen über irgendwelche Schiedsrichter an den letzten Spieltagen. Nun ja, schauen wir nochmal in die Niederlande. Daniel, da habe ich den Eindruck, dass vorhin mit Rüben von Bommel vielleicht schon einer derjenigen genannt worden sein könnte, über die du jetzt kurz sprechen willst.
So ist es, denn was wirklich auffällt in der letzten Zeitperiode, dass sehr, sehr viele Söhne mit berühmten Namen jetzt in den Jugendmannschaften spielen. Und nicht nur in den Jugendmannschaften, auch teilt schon in den Profi-Afteilungen. Zum Beispiel eben Rüben von Bommel, der Sohn von Marc von Bommel, der ist jetzt für, ich glaube, 15 Millionen von AZ zu Fays Way gekommen, ist Flügelspieler und ist eigentlich, war schon auf dem besten Weg, seine Luftmarken zu unterlassen. Sechs Spieler, schon drei Tore erzielt. Auch in der Rebensliga schon ein Tor gemacht für Fays Way. Und dann kam eben die schon erwähnte blöde Knieverletzung, die ihn wirklich bis kommendes Jahr wohl außer Gefecht setzt. Das ist echt tragisch. Aber wenn man in der Liga schaut, hat man auch im aktuellen Profi-Bereich, zum Beispiel bei Telstar, hat man den Sohn von Ronald Koeman, der da heißt Ronald Koeman Junior. Und der steht im Tor bei Telstar und macht die Sache auch sehr solide. Oder zum Beispiel Sidney van Houdonck, der war auch, glaube ich, mal in Bologna, in Italien, ist jetzt bei Breda, spielt mit Hoepie zusammen. Und der hat ja auch einen bekannten Vater, Pierre van Houdonck, der war bei Feyernoord. Und wenn man sich in die Jugendabteilung anguckt, wir haben einen Leim, Liam van Nistelrooy, der Mittelstürmer ist. Wir haben einen Sepp Hüntelaar, auch bei PSV, der ist 16, ist auch Mittelstürmer. Wir haben bei Feyernoord in der Jugend den Sohn von Robin van Persie. Wir haben bei Milan, auch international, haben wir den Sohn von Clement Seedorf, der ist 18. Wir haben bei Ajax Demian van der Vaart, der ist 19. Wir haben Wissi Sneijder, der ist 19, bei Utrecht. Wir haben einen Kläuferd bei Barca, der ist 18. Die sind alle in dieser Generation, die sind alle 16 bis 18 Jahre. Und die sind auch alle relativ sanitär, das man so hört. Das heißt, die spielen auch teilweise auch niederländische Bundeskommandmannschaft. Schon. Das heißt, in so 3, 4 Jahren werde ich mal sehr gespannt, welche bekannten Namen wir alle im Team haben. Wir könnten die ganze Generation quasi wiederholen. Also, das ist mir aufgefallen. Und gerade auch jetzt, weil zum Beispiel so ein Leim von Nistelreus und PSV, der ist diese Saison jetzt in die Nachwuchsabteilung gewechselt zu PSV. Und die sind auch alle sehr nah dran am Rufebereich, wenn es die Älteren von denen. Und insofern könnte Rüben van Mummel quasi ein Vorbild sein für viele andere junge Spieler. Das ist ja mal ein bisschen die Frage, ist der Name dann Segen oder Fluch oder Segen? Jetzt ist es zu großer Druck, was noch medial oftmals dann generiert wird. Bislang scheint das noch nicht so der Fall zu sein, was aber auch damit zu tun hat, dass sie eben noch sehr junge sind und eben noch nicht in die Poko stehen. Spannend wird es dann, wenn sie wirklich dann mal in den Rufebereich kommen. Bei van Mummel hat man jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass das ein großes Ding für ihn ist. Wie es dann bei allen anderen, die es ja wirklich zuhauf gibt, so aussehen wird, das lässt sich natürlich erst in ein paar Jahren sagen. Aber da könnte man auf jeden Fall ein Auge drauf haben, auf wie sie bekannten waren.
Absolut fantastisch. Also das niederländische Nationalteam könnte aussehen, wie ich es in PS5 gespielt habe, glaube ich. Das ist ja wirklich großartig.
Sie sind leider nur sehr oft im Offensivbereich. Also die würden sich dann gegenseitig Kürze wegnehmen. Also es ist positionell unausgewogen.
Hat Edwin van der Saar etwa nur Töchter oder was da los?
Das ist mir ja riesenbekannt, aber das wird sich auf wenigstens auch mal rausfinden.
Was heißt denn da nur Töchter? Das niederländische Frauen-Nationalteam ist, würde ich mal sagen, erfolgreicher als das der Männer.
Der junge Werdergolf Hesseling ist auch schon da.
Ja, ist schon da. Der müsste bei Twente spielen.
Ach, ganz fantastisch. Also das war ein sehr schönes letztes Thema. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall einen Blick drauf. Ihr vier. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Vielen Dank an Jakob Haffke, Daniel Zander, Uli Hebel und an Nils Kern, den wir übrigens vielleicht doch gesehen haben. Ich habe hier noch so– ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich habe gesehen, hier gibt es jetzt zwei Nilse auf einmal in der Aufnahme. Aber die wirklich sehen wir erst, wenn das Licht angeht, wenn die Dateien hochgeladen sind. Deswegen mal sehen. Ihr wisst es schon.
Bei Tiki-Taka hört man mich auch nicht. Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt sieht man mich nicht mehr.
Immer diese Insider. Aber damit haben wir ja auch schon elegant darauf hingewiesen. Ihr könnt sehr gerne in den Show Notes mal gucken, wo man die vier sonst noch so lesen und eben auch hören kann. Denn ich weiß ja, die Ligatour kommt manchen von euch nicht oft genug, aber es gibt ja genügend andere Podcasts, in denen ja genau auch Leute wie hier auch noch zu hören sind. Also schaut einfach mal in die Show Notes oder in die Videobeschreibung. Ich danke euch vier und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn diese Sendung hier ist von euch allein finanziert. Wir sind und bleiben Paywall-Werbe- und Sponsoren-frei, finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de, da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und natürlich auch eine Videobeschreibung und den Show Notes. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Joris, bei Sebastian, bei Ran, Milo, Ran, bei Schützi und bei Holli90. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Ansonsten empfehlt uns sehr gerne weiter, abonniert die anderen Formate des Rasenfunks. Hier geht es dann weiter am Sonntag mit einer Folge zur 2. Liga der Männer. Ansonsten wisst ihr ja, es gibt ein großes Programm beim Rasenfunk. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald wieder. Macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.